it's been almost a month since the m2
macbook air was released and now that
the hype is settled down let's get real
is it really worth spending way more
money on the 14-inch macbook pro well
today i'm gonna compare everything from
a honest real world perspective and keep
it short and sweet after five years
apple finally redesigned the macbook air
and looks modern but a bit retro at the
same time the 14-inch looks like a
chunkier version of the air but the
extra thickness brings features that can
make a real difference in usability
since i mentioned design let's start
with that the pro looks bigger bulkier
and a bit meaner where the air is thin
and sleek the wet shape is now gone and
personally i'm a bit sad about it since
it was so iconic and it didn't dig into
your wrist for really long typing
sessions but in the real world the new
design is still thin enough not to
matter one weird thing is that online
they look very similar and the specs
seem so close but in the real world you
really notice the weight difference and
the thickness i personally find that the
thicker pro can dig into your wrists and
even though the keyboards have the same
name the airs feels better in my opinion
having a bit more feedback so if you do
a lot of typing you'll prefer the m2 air
one disappointment though with the new
air are the speakers apple made a huge
deal about the quad speakers with
dedicated woofers so we had high
expectations but in reality they got
quieter and with less steer separation
as they got rid of the speaker holes on
the sides and instead they fire towards
the display the 14-inch on the other
hand has the best speakers in any laptop
of this size go ahead and take a listen
[Music]
the difference is shocking with a huge
difference in volume and bass and if
you're somebody that will constantly be
playing them at full blast you will
really enjoy them i know i do now with
that said if i'm being honest if you are
not comparing them side by side the air
speakers still sound good and for most
people they are much better than the
laptop that it will replace with that we
have new ports which your current laptop
may or may not have now i love that
magsafe is back on both of these and on
the air that means that the two
thunderbolt ports are free to use at any
time now yes the 14-inch has one more
thunderbolt and it's more powerful as
well as hdmi and a card reader so if
yours has that now i would track how
often you use those things now for me
most of the time i just use usb type c
and even though dongles suck you should
really ask yourself is it really worth
spending the extra cash to have them
built in instead of buying a cheap
multi-adapter i'll link this one in the
description it's been working great and
i just keep it in my laptop bag now as
for the webcams based on specs they seem
the same being 1080p but we definitely
noticed a difference this is the new
1080p webcam in the m2 macbook air now
it did get a lot better compared to the
720p but the 14 inch macbook pro that
also has a 1080p webcam has less noise a
bit more detail so i think it must be
just the camera module that apple is
using after webcams now is a really good
time to talk about fan noise or lack
thereof if you're somebody who
constantly does zoom meetings and your
current laptop might get annoying
because after a while the fans will spin
up and keep it cool as it processes that
video feed which was a huge issue with
the intel macbook air and that also
impacted audio quality the m2 air is
fanless so it is silent but if you might
be worried about the 14-inch pro because
it does have dual fans thankfully for
most tasks the fans are literally turned
off thanks to apple silicon being very
efficient and since the heat pipes pull
away heat from the processors even if
the fans are off now if you're doing
tough tasks yes they will spin up but
they are still very quiet some people
have mentioned that the m2 air's bottom
case can get really hot with extended
loads and that is true the 14 inch
exhausts the heat upwards away from you
but the fanless m2 air's bottom case can
reach 47 degrees celsius since the heat
is literally trapped in there and up to
108 degrees celsius internally which is
much hotter than the 14 inch if you're
wondering how this impacts performance
without a fan well in our detailed
testing we found that it can lose 17 of
its performance after about 10 minutes
and that is just with cpu tasks as far
as graphics the performance loss can be
over 26
and if you're loading both up at the
same time it could be even more than
that so if you're pushing your mac hard
and you're loading up the cpu and the
graphics the pro is the way to go but if
you need to save some cash and you want
a thin and light design a thin laptop
cooler can make a surprising difference
just by itself i'll go ahead and link
the cooler and the full video in the
description so what about performance
especially if the tasks you do don't
completely max up the cpu for a long
time well this is the reason why most
people would buy the 14-inch pro instead
of the air and it might be the biggest
reason why you're considering it well i
want to challenge you a little bit and
also give you some more info i just want
you to take a second and ask yourself
how much performance do you really need
first off the 2 000 14 inch macbook pro
is the double bin version meaning to get
the full m1 pro chip it costs at least 2
300 and second even the base m2 ear
already beats out even the previous best
16-inch macbook pro in many tasks and
absolutely wipes the floor with the
intel macbook airs in the real world the
air has more than enough performance for
most people even for difficult tasks but
i do have to add that we are using a 512
gigabyte ssd model of the air because
the base 256 gigabyte has a slow ssd
that will not only slow down transfers
but your whole machine if you are
multitasking and doing productive work
now the m2 chip sounds like it could be
better than the m1 pro and it actually
can for a few tasks which i'll mention
but the base 14-inch has six performance
cores two more than the air because of
that the multi-core score isn't that
much higher with the difference of only
eleven percent and this test shows a lot
of various computing tasks so most won't
even notice it in the real world as for
single core the m2 beats out the 14 inch
by nine percent because of its faster
clock speeds which also gives it a good
advantage in web-based application
performance but once again both are so
fast that you probably won't notice what
you will notice though is the difference
in battery life apple specs show that
the m2 air only gets one extra hour of
battery life with the fine print showing
that it's based on video playback but
that's not the truth for real world use
we found that for mixed use the battery
life is worse and a bigger difference
between them and for top tasks the
difference is even greater since the 14
inch can use a lot more power adding on
to that if you use low power mode both
laptops are still very fast but the m2
air can last up to 15 hours because it
will only use 2 watts for the cpu and
1.5 for the graphics that is because it
has 4 efficiency cores and there are new
ones that are much more powerful while
being more efficient now the 14 inch
pro's battery life doesn't improve too
much because it has to keep using the
performance cores as it only has two
efficiency cords that are much worse so
the cpu actually uses about 15 watts
compared to an average of two and using
that mode on the m2 air results in the
machine running super cool and the
bottom not heating up at all so if you
really care about battery life the
macbook air is the clear choice check
out the video if you want to get a lot
more info now when you do need full
performance for more than 10 minutes the
stock m2 air loses by about 30 in cpu
and for graphics by more than double
because the stock macbook air throttles
a lot after just four to five minutes
now if you use the cooling solution that
we showed them to air won't throttle but
it's still a 63 difference which is
massive and spending an extra hundred
dollars for better graphics is mostly a
waste in our testing so if you're doing
graphics heavy tasks like gaming or
productivity tasks that rely on graphics
this is where the 14-inch pro really
starts to stand out and combining both
can make a slightly more pricey 14-inch
if spec the same ending up being more
than twice as fast and a much better
machine to have but let's get real most
of you wanting the air probably won't be
working on raw footage but you're gonna
be using it for web browsing and some
light productivity and maybe some normal
creative work here the differences
aren't massive with the 14 inch only
being slightly faster for photography
and since both are so fast compared to
old intel macbooks in the real world i
had no complaints especially with the 16
gigabyte macbook air which is the one to
get if you're going to be doing
productive tasks and even for things
like compiling code the air can keep up
very well and for simple 4k video
editing with effects it can actually
beat out the 14-inch using the latest
version of davinci resolve which is now
fully optimized for the m2 chip so i
would say that there is only a small
group of people who really need the
extra power of the 14 inch pro but when
you need it like for extended 100 loads
especially with graphics you really need
it and with that comes the mini led xdr
display that is capable of hitting up to
1600 nits instead of 500. now for normal
use you don't really notice a difference
but when it comes time for hdr either
viewing or editing the 14 inch gives you
a much better experience with really
great contrast and brightness that the
m2 air simply cannot achieve as well as
120hz pro motion for super smooth
scrolling which to be honest i didn't
notice as much as i do on my iphone and
also being able to play games at above
60 fps personally unless you know that
you want or need many of the benefits
that the 14 inch provides that we talked
about i think that the air is a great
machine and it is much more pleasant for
taking on the go seriously it's a big
difference but if you don't mind the
size and you can't afford it you do get
a lot more bang for the buck with the 14
inch macbook pro especially if you buy
it discounted on amazon i'll go ahead
and leave the best deals down in the
video description go ahead and check out
one of those must watch videos right
over there especially if you want to buy
an m2 macbook air and click above to
subscribe if this video brought you some
value this has been max max tech and i
will see you in the next video
[Music]